[Music]
welcome to session number 64 in the
worlds of speculative fiction series in
this session we are going to be
returning once again to one of my
favorite authors Philip K dick and we're
going to be looking at three novels
specifically one of them is contained in
this four volume set it's the Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep and this is the
library of America
Edition that has several other really
important novels in it but we're really
going to be focusing closely on that one
if you don't know that that novel it's
the one that was adapted into the movie
The Blade Runner and then we're going to
be looking at two other novels that deal
with you could say similar themes one is
we can build you and the other is the
simulacra now what are all of these
novels have in common
Androids or robots and human beings and
a central theme for Philip K dick before
we get too far into it though what I
should say for anybody who's new to this
series is that world's a speculative
fiction started out in 2016 as a monthly
in-person talk and discussion session
which I video recorded and you can see
all of the earlier video recordings of
the 63 episodes or installations before
this
going all the way back to January of
2016 and it was hosted at one of the
local libraries here in the greater
Milwaukee area the Brookfield Public
Library was so gracious as to offer a
space and people got quite interested in
all of these discussions about World
building and philosophical themes in
speculative fiction which includes you
know science fiction fantasy the Blends
between them horror alternate history uh
you know utopian dystopian all sorts of
other
genres that are kind of Blended together
and so we continued having these more or
less monthly sessions until covet hit
and then once covid hit obviously we
couldn't meet in the library anymore and
after a while I decided let's take it
online so I'm doing what I started back
then which is to shoot a video I'll be
discussing Philip K dick and these
novels a few essays by him as well and
some other things that we'll talk about
in just a moment and that'll run for 90
to 100 minutes depending on how much I
get done how much I can pack in we're
going to talk a lot about philosophical
themes about what Dick's own views on
these matters are some of the key
characters the World building and his
attitudes towards uh the future that
that we're going to be exploring
and then we follow it up with a video
conferencing session for people who want
to engage in a little bit more
um
q a discussion not necessarily
one-on-one but a smaller group but with
the video that you're seeing right now
we run it with a Premiere and people can
do live chat on the side weigh in I'm
watching it at the same time as they are
and so we have a really great time so I
you know if you're on the premiere
that's awesome if you're seeing this
later well you can say things in the
comments and you if you want to and I'll
respond to them
and I'll definitely be talking much more
about Philip K dick and these particular
themes in the future so the key idea
here is Androids and humans and I do
want to point something out that I
discovered in this uh these shifting
realities of Philip K dick selected
literary and philosophical writings very
interesting volume so this is something
that he wrote in 1981 shortly before
he's he's going to die and he's talking
about one of his earliest short stories
which you may have read called Beyond
lies the wob and he says when I wrote
this back in my youth and politically
active Berkeley I would never have
thought of the crucial ingredient in the
wob being a soul I was a fireball
radical an atheist and religion was
totally foreign to me however even in
those days is I was about 22 years old I
was casting about in an effort to
contrast the truly human from what I was
later to call the Android or reflex
machine that looks human but is not the
subject of the speech I gave in
Vancouver in 1972 the Android and the
human 20 years after Beyond lies the wob
was published The Germ of the idea
behind the speech lies in this my first
published story it has to do with
empathy or as it was called in earlier
times
karitas or Agape so isn't that
interesting these stories that we're
going to be looking at here uh you know
we can build you the simulacra into
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep are
dealing with things that dick was
interested in from the very start we're
also going to do something else that's a
little bit of a I hope it's a treat but
maybe it'll be a bit of a chore
this is a thing that's called the
exegesis of Philippe dick you notice
that it is quite a Tome you could
probably break walnuts with this on a
hard table and this is you know Dick's
own notes that he's writing about things
as it turns out to Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep and to a lesser extent
these other novels
in his View
aren't just about Androids and humans
they play a role in his trying to figure
out
reality itself so the other
major major themes of Philip K Dick's
writings are intricately connected to
this question of what is distinctively
human
what pretends to be human but isn't how
do human beings devolve from being
genuinely human into Androids or
something analogous to that and how does
this figure in to you know issues like
empathy or lava or agape and the
universe
as a totality so these are some of the
key ideas that were going to be
exploring so buckle in we got a lot of
cool stuff to run through over the next
and roughly 90 minutes maybe a little
bit shorter maybe a little bit longer
depending on how much I pack into this
as I mentioned earlier but this is
really really Central to Philip K Dick's
works and I consider dick to be a great
novelist uh short story writer but also
something of a philosopher himself so
this is going to be probably one of my
favorite videos about uh one of my
favorite authors to produce and
hopefully it'll be stimulating and
thought provoking for you
before we get into the philosophical
themes that are raised and there's a lot
of them by this contrast between
human beings fully human beings and
Androids or Similac and then the area in
between where there are human beings
that are reduced to something like
reflex machines we should talk a bit
about the worlds and also about the uh
nature of the human beings and the
Androids that are involved in these
novels now interestingly when we bring
together simulacra we can build you and
the Android's Dream of Electric Sheep
there are some common themes that come
up and we also see this echoed in one
other novel in which Androids or
simulacra play a minor role the Martian
time slip and that is Mars and
colonization
the uh you know world in in some of
these has not been wrecked the way it
has been for example in Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep where there's been a
war and radioactivity has killed off a
lot of the animals in uh the similacra
we have a United States that merged with
West Germany and somehow Nazi ideology
came in and it's kind of a dystopian
future people living in these giant
apartment building blocks but there's
also the possibility of going off to
other places
um you know for as colonists you can
actually like buy a jalopy to do so
right uh in in we can build you we've
got something that's a little bit closer
to our own time somebody has brought up
a lot of the Martian real estate and
moon real estate and are trying to sell
these these sorts of things to people
and there aren't many similar Locker yet
developed and we can build you and
there's actually only one that matters
in the simulacra and that that's the
simulacra of the Alta the president of
the United States and and Europe right
um in the Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep there are a number of Androids
that are being built by various
corporations particularly the Rosen
Corporation
and they're actually doing the building
off-site a lot of human beings have
actually left the Earth and are going
out as colonists to other places because
the Earth is you know not completely
ruined but there's a lot of things wrong
with it and we should also talk about
very briefly the Martian time slip in
which colonization is taking place on
Mars as well and that might actually be
an interesting place to begin talking
about the various Androids now
there's two places in that novel where
this comes up and I think what you see
here is kind of similar to what's going
on in the simulacra these are non-mobile
simulacra that are requiring you know
some maintenance and they have certain
functions so
um
in in the very first chapter right we
have this going on several times he'd
visited the public school with his son
that was different David was at the top
of his class attending the most advanced
teaching machines along the Route he
stayed late making the most of the
tutorial system of which the UN was so
proud now uh what are these teaching
machines Androids David was with the
Aristotle learning the rudiments of
science philosophy logic rammer Poetics
and an archaic physics of all the
teaching machines David seemed to derive
the most from the Aristotle which was a
relief many of the children prefer the
more dashing teachers at the school Sir
Francis Drake English History
fundamentals of masculine civility or
Abraham Lincoln United States history
basics of modern warfare in the
Contemporary state or such Grim
personages as Julius Caesar and Winston
Churchill he himself had been born too
soon to take advantage of the tutorial
school system he'd gone to classes as a
boy where he sat with 60 other children
later in high school he'd found himself
listening and watching an instructor
speaking over close circuit TV along
with a class of a thousand if however he
had been allowed into the new school he
could have readily located his own
favorite on a visit with David on the
very first parent-teacher day in fact he
had seen the Thomas Edison teaching
machine and that was enough for him it
took David almost an hour to drag his
father away right and a little bit later
we find Jack who's this character going
to the school and he roams around
wondering where the boy had gone ahead a
group of children that collected around
a teacher
a tall white-haired bushy brow gentleman
who Jack recognized as Mark Twain
Manfred however was not among them as
Jack started to walk past the Mark Twain
it broke off its monologue to the
children puffed several times on a cigar
and called after Jack my friend can I be
of any assistance to you
Jackson I'm looking for a little boy I
brought here with me I know all the
young fellows the Mark Twain teaching
machine answered what's his name Manfred
Steiner he described the boy as t as the
teaching machine listened alertly hmm it
said when he had finished smoked for a
moment then once more lowered its cigar
I believe you will find that young man
over colloquializing with the Roman
Emperor Tiberius or at least so I am
informed by the authorities in whose
care this organization has been
entrusted I speak of the master circuit
sir
Tiberius he had not realized such
figures were represented here at the
public school the base and deranged
personages of History evidently from his
expression the Mark Twain understood his
thoughts here in the school it informed
him as examples not to be emulated but
to be avoided with the most scrupulous
Zeal you will find sir as you make your
peregrinations about these Halls that
many Rascals Pirates and scamps are on
display sermonizing and dolorous and
lamentable tones they're edifying
histories for the enlightenment of the
young the Mark Twain again puffing on
its cigar winked at him disconcerted
Jack hurried on I do want to read you
this this other little part here
at the Immanuel Kant he stopped to ask
directions several pupils in their teens
stood aside for him the Tiberius had
told him in heavily accented English can
be found down that way appointed with
absolute Authority it did not have any
doubts and Jack hurried at once down
that particular Hall so in in Martian
time slip and you could also say well
really in the simulacra and we can build
you it's going to be important famous
people who are made into Androids made
into teaching machines Similac or
whatever we want to call them and in the
simulacra itself we're at a very
important point where one of the
um
uh similacra who is the you know the
president the Alta or der Alta is going
to be replaced by a new one every so
often they have the simulacra
have a simulated medical problem and
then you know there's a succession of of
power so that's you know that's quite
interesting as well
um
and we can build you at first they're
thinking about
um
creating
simulacra or Androids of a whole bunch
of different people and having Civil War
battles reenacted fought you know by uh
Android soldiers on each side and so
what they decide to do is to create
first
Edwin M Stanton and then to create an
Abraham Lincoln right so here's here's a
uh important passage thank you Jerome
Morey said this Edwin M Stanton
electronic simulacrum it's as good as if
Stanton had been alive here discussing
topics with us what a sales idea that is
for educational purposes like in the
schools but there's nothing I had that
in mind at first but here's the
authentic deal listen we proposed to
president Mendoza in our nation's
capital that we abolish war and
substitute for it a 10-year space depart
Centennial the U.S Civil War and what we
do is the Rosen Factory supplies all the
participants to Malacca that's the
plural it's a Latin type word of
everybody Linton Stanton Jeff Davis
Robert E Lee Longstreet and around three
million simple ones as soldiers we keep
in stock all the time and we have the
battles fought with the participants
really killed he's made to order some
Malacca blown to bits instead of just B
grade movie type business like a bunch
of college kids doing Shakespeare do you
get my point you see the scope of this
and we are all silent yes I thought
there is scope to it we could be as big
as General Dynamics in five years my
father eyed him smoking is a and c I
don't know Maurice I don't know why not
tell me Jerome what's wrong with it the
times have carried you away perhaps my
father said in a slow voice tinged with
weariness or am I getting old right and
they go on and they they create an
adword Stanton uh Similac which we'll
talk about it in just a bit then they
create an Abraham Lincoln now their
rival and much larger organization run
by
the uh kind of shady Tycoon you could
say uh is uh going to
um create a John Wilkes Booth but it's
not a very good one like the Stanton and
the Lincoln are as as we'll talk about
um what about and Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep the the really Central
novel that all of this I would say turns
around for dick well
there aren't a lot of famous Android
replicants Similac or whatever we want
to call them
instead there's a number of different
models and they're created for
particular purposes and they're not
allowed on Earth they're created for the
outworld colonies and they actually do
carry out a good bit of the colonization
now that's also coming up in we can
build you this idea that you could like
go and be a colonist and then you would
have essentially some indentured servant
simulacra who would be doing work for
you that comes up there as well but in
the Android stream of electric sheep
that becomes an absolutely Central
feature of you could call it the
narrative Universe you've got all of
these uh Androids who are not
particularly happy about their
circumstances and some of them every
once in a while will commit crimes and
break out and come to Earth and then we
have uh the you know Rick Deckard and
his his companions who are Hunters of
these Androids and they belong to the
police department and that's what they
specialize in so there's there's a lot
of scope for talking about uh what's
going on here I'm less uh focused
directly on plot and more thinking about
what's revealed to us about these
various characters some of whom are
human some of whom are Android there's
one other thing that we should point out
too that comes up in uh we can build you
and in uh do Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep and that is the fundamental
difference between you could say a fully
developed fully functioning human being
and
um
Androids there are other human beings
who could be as dick is going to call
them schizoid or schizophrenia can also
do this or psychosis these forms of
mental illness they steer a person
towards what he's going to call in his
famous essay the Android and the human
androidization becoming kind of detached
affectless
reflex machines this is also we should
point out before ending this little
segment this is also a very important
point in the later novel
A Scanner Darkly where it has to do
instead with the you know destruction of
human brains through drug addiction and
Indulgence in these these various drugs
right where people are reduced the word
there is reduced to insects that are
just mere stimulus response machines so
so some very important
um you know aspects to these stories
Androids humans what are the Androids
actually used for why are they there how
do they fit into the Human Social world
the economic world the world of human
Affairs it's a little bit different from
story to story but there are some quite
important common themes shared across
these novels
the theme of Androids and humans comes
up a lot in Philip K Dick's work and
also in his own thought about his work
to which we should now turn to get a
better understanding before delving back
into these novels and there's really
three pieces that I want to talk about
one we'll look at at considerable length
called just the Android and the human
from a 1972 address that he gives and
then there's a sort of follow-up to it
man Android and machine from 1976. much
of which is actually not your main to
our topic but I want to begin with his
other address how to build a universe
from 1978
and there's two things that he says
there that I think are kind of
interesting he says I ask in my writing
what is real metaphysical and
epistemological question right because
unceasingly we are bombarded with
pseudo-realities manufactured by very
sophisticated people using very
sophisticated electronic mechanisms I
don't just trust their motives I
distrust their power they have a lot of
it and it's an astonishing power that of
creating whole universes universes of
the mind I ought to know I do the same
thing it's my job to create universes is
the basis of one novel after another and
I have to build them in such a way that
they don't fall apart two days later or
at least that is what my editors hope
however
I will reveal a secret to you I like to
build universes that do fall apart I
like to see them come unglued and I like
to see how the characters in the novels
cope with this problem I have a secret
love of chaos there should be more of it
do not believe and I am dead serious
when I say this do not assume that order
and stability are always good in a
society or in a universe the old the
ossified must always give way to a new
life and the birth of new things before
the new things can be born the old must
perish this is a dangerous realization
because it tells us we must eventually
part with much of what is familiar to us
and that hurts but that is part of the
script of Life unless we can
psychologically accommodate change we
ourselves will begin to die inwardly
what I'm saying is that objects Customs
habits and ways of life must perish so
that the authentic human being can live
and it is the authentic human being who
matters most the viable elastic organism
that can bounce back absorb and deal
with the new so that's one important
thing that he's saying from how to build
a universe and then a little bit later
he'll say
I consider that the matter of defining
what is real that is a serious topic
even a vital topic and in there
somewhere is the other topic the
definition of the authentic human
because the bombardment of
pseudo-realities begins to produce
inauthentic humans very quickly spurious
humans as fake as the data pressing at
them from all sides my two topics are
really one topic they unite at this
point fake realities will create fake
humans or fake humans will generate fake
realities and then sell them to other
humans turning them eventually into
forgeries of themselves so we wind up
with fake humans inventing fake
realities and then peddling them to
other fake humans it is just a very
large version of Disneyland you can have
the pirate ride or the Lincoln some
lacrum and Mr told's Wild Ride you can
have them all but none is true so that's
a very interesting set of points that
he's making there I mean think about how
much more true this is in a world
permeated by virtual reality in the
technosphere that we live in at present
and we're going to work our way
backwards let's talk now about this
rather longish peace man Android and
machine much of which ends up being
about things that don't have much to do
with Androids and a lot to do with
cosmology
so he begins uh with you know
similar points to the Android and the
human and then he's going to diverge he
says within the universe there exists
Fierce cold things which I have given
the name machines to their behavior
frightens me especially when it imitates
human behavior so well that I get the
uncomfortable sense that these things
are trying to pass themselves off as
humans but are not I call them Androids
which is my own way of using that word
by Android I don't mean a sincere
attempt to create a laboratory a human
being as we saw for example in the TV
film the quester tapes I mean a thing
somehow generated to deceive us in a
cruel way to cause us to think it be one
of ourselves
made in a laboratory that aspect is not
meaningful to me the entire universe is
one vast laboratory and out of it comes
Sly and cruel entities that smile as
they reach out to shake hands but their
hands Shake is the grip of death and
their smile has the coldness of the
Grave these creatures are among us the
morphologically they do not differ from
us
we must not posit a difference of
essence but a difference of behavior in
my science fiction I write about them
constantly
sometimes they do not know their
Androids like Rachel Rosen they can be
pretty but somehow lack something or
like pris and we can build you they can
absolutely be born of a human womb and
even design Androids the Abraham Lincoln
and the book and themselves be without
warmth they fall within the clinical
entities schizoid which means lacking
proper feeling I'm sure we mean the same
thing here with the emphasis on the word
thing a human being without the proper
empathy or feeling is the same as an
Android built to lack at either by
Design or mistake now notice what he's
going to say here this is really
absolutely Central we mean basically
someone who does not care about the Fate
that his fellow living creatures fall
victim to he stands detached a spectator
acting out by his indifference John
Dunn's theorem that no man is an island
but giving the theorem a Twist that
which is mental and a moral island is
not a man
so he goes on a little bit further and
he says you know there's some
interesting speculations here about
masks and we need to be careful in what
we assume to be underneath the mask he
says I made a mistake at one point in
time I supposed only bad people were
frightening masks but you can now see I
fell for the magic of the Mask it's
Dreadful frightening magic it's illusion
I bought the illusion the deception and
fled I now wish to apologize to you for
preaching that deception to someone
something genuine I've had you all
sitting around the campfire with our
eyes wide with alarm as I tell tales of
the Hideous monsters I encountered my
Voyage of Discovery ended in terrifying
Visions I dutifully carried home with me
as I fled back to safety safety from
what from something which when the need
was gone for concealment smiled and
revealed its harmlessness and then he
goes on and he says
I don't intend to abandon my dichotomy
between what I call human and what I
call Android the latter being a cruel
and cheap mockery of the former for base
ends but I had been going on Surface
appearances to distinguish the
categories more cunning is required for
if a gentle harmless life conceals
itself behind a frightening War mask
then it is likely that behind gentle and
loving masks there can conceal itself a
vicious Slayer of men's souls in either
case can we go on Surface appearance we
must penetrate to the heart of each to
the heart of the subject so how do we
figure out
what is real in the sense of the
authentically human oh this is where we
want to turn back to his earlier address
the Android and the human and he begins
by saying the distinction between
mechanism and organic human being is is
breaking down and not just because we
use all of this technology that we
incorporate into our our own you know
bodies in many cases or interfaces but
also because the machines are becoming
so sophisticated they're taking on
animation
and he says that in a very real sense
our environment is becoming alive or at
least quasi alive and in ways
specifically and fundamentally
analogous to ourselves and he says you
know we need to think about this analogy
uh in both directions
and he he's worried about what you can
call so he says in some of my stories
and novels I've written about Androids
or robots or similacra the name doesn't
matter
what is meant is artificial constructs
masquerading as humans usually with a
Sinister purpose in mind I suppose I
took it for granted that it's such a
construct a robot for example had a
benign or anyhow decent purpose in mind
it would not need to disguise itself
now that's a very interesting thing to
say because in we can build you
the simulacra are not disguising
themselves we know that Stanton and
Linda Lincoln are in fact simulacra but
they're pretty benign right in the
simulacra itself of course the great
secret is that
the president is in fact a Android an
Android who just sits in one place and
so that secret is being concealed and
then of course in the Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep we have Androids trying
to pass themselves off as humans which
necessitates the bounty hunters in a
martian time slip we have the teaching
machines which clearly are Similac or
Androids but everybody knows that they
are as well so going on with this right
he says the constructs this theme seems
to be obsolete the constructs do not
mimic humans they are in many deep ways
already human already they're not trying
to fool us they follow lines that we
follow right
so you know how can we in fact tell the
differences between them and he's got
some interesting speculations here that
I'm going to skip over and then he says
I want to ask you this
what is it in our behavior that we call
specifically human
what's special to us as a living species
what is it that at least up till now we
can consign as merely machine Behavior
or by extension insect Behavior reflex
behavior and I would include in this the
kind of pseudo-human behavior exhibited
by once what were once living human
beings creatures who have in ways I wish
to discuss next become instruments means
rather than ends and hence to me analogs
of machines in the bad sense and Dick
thinks that this can happen in a lot of
different ways he talks about reading a
Gestapo file and realizing that these
people who complain about the noise
that's made by Starving Children
disrupting their sleep in the night
there's something inhuman about that
something a lack a loss of humanity
involved in in that right so what in
fact makes us human
and he um talks about you know young
people I'm actually going to skip over
that it's quite interesting the things
that he brings up but I do want to bring
up this line
um
he says this war that we're fighting to
maintain an augment what is human about
us what is the core of ourselves and the
source of our destiny our flight must
not be only to the stars but into the
nature of our own beings
it's not merely where we go to alphas
and Centaurus or Betelgeuse but where we
are as we make our pilgrimages there our
Natures will be going there too and
Astra that is to the stars but as human
beings we must never lose sight of that
right so how can we make sense out of
what is like us
he talks about one thing as
irreplaceability
right
um he he says even the most base schemes
of human beings are preferable to the
most exalted tropisms of machines I
think that this right here is one of the
valid insights possessed by some of the
new youth cars even police cars are
expendable can be replaced they're
really all alike
it's the person inside who wants gone
cannot be duplicated at any price even
if we don't like him we cannot do
without him and once gone he will never
come back so if he's made into an
Android he will never come back never be
human again or all anyway most likely
will not right and so he talks about
this new individuality of the kids we
might applaud it as you know being
irresponsible or anti-social but also as
meaningful and so he he goes on and he
says
this danger of androidization becoming
what I call for lack of a better term
means as I said to allow oneself to
become a means to be pounded down
manipulated made into a means without
one's knowledge or consent the results
are the same you cannot turn a human
into an Android if that human is going
to break laws ever get chance he gets
androidization requires obedience and
most of all predictability
so that's one thing about the Android
right
um it becomes programmed the human being
as following programs is androidized you
could say
I'm going on a little bit further uh
he's talking about the state apparatus
and totalitarian society and technology
and all of these concerns about that and
how the kids are all right he also goes
into some discussions about drugs that
I'm going to skip over because we're
mostly interested here in the question
of androidization so he says one way to
tell the Androids apart from humans and
this is something that we're going to
see particularly in the Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep he says in the field
of abnormal psychology the schizoid
personality structure is well developed
there is a continual paucity a lack of
feeling the person thinks rather than
feels his way towards through life right
one must meet a crucial reality with a
feeling response to remain human there's
a certain parallel between what I call
the Android personality and the schizoid
both have a mechanical reflex quality
right and this is another uh
characteristic of the Android mind is
the inability to make exceptions and
this makes sense if we're thinking about
programming right and Rule following and
all of those things that go along with
it
not knowing when to make an exception to
the rule don't throw the rule away but
make exceptions when they're needed this
is part of what is authentically human
and he says perhaps this is the essence
of the Android the failure to drop a
response when it fails to accomplish
results but rather to repeat it over and
over again Lower life forms are skillful
in offering the same response
continually as are flashlights
an attempt was made to use a pigeon as a
quality control technician on an
assembly line part after part endless
thousands of them past the pigeon hour
after hour and the key Kenai the pigeon
viewed them for deviations from the
acceptable tolerance the pigeon could
discern a deviation smaller than that of
the human
doing the same quality control could
so when the pigeon saw a part that was
mis-made it pecked a button which
rejected the part and at the same time
dropped a grain of corn to the pigeon as
reward the pigeon could go 18 hours
without fatigue and loved its work even
when the grain corn failed due to supply
running out the pigeon continued to
eagerly to reject substandard Parts it
had to be forcibly removed from its
perch finally and Dick says man if I was
that pigeon you know what I would do I'd
Peck stuff all the time and eat as much
corn as I want I would subvert it I
would
um
break it down right he goes on as well
and he says that
um let me now Express another element
that strikes me as an essential key
revealing the authentically human
and this is very this is absolutely
important
it is not only an intrinsic property the
organism itself right but the situation
in which it finds itself now we should
pause there for a moment
we often want to think about things in
terms of the entities and not the larger
Matrix that they're within particularly
when we're thinking about artificial
intelligence or you know
um how we're going to differentiate
human-like things from the humans
dick is on to something really important
here
he says
that which happens to it that which it
is confronted by pierced by and much
must deal with certain agonizing
situations create on the spot a human
where a moment before there was only as
the Bible says clay
such a situation can be read off the
face of many of the medieval pietas
these uh images right the dead Christ
held in the arms of his mother two faces
that of a man that of a woman oddly in
many of these the face of Christ seems
older than that of his mother it is as
if an ancient man is held by a young
woman she has survived him and yet she
came before him and this is you know
sort of an example and he says I've seen
young women
18 19 years old suffer and survive
things that would have been too much for
me and I think for almost any man their
humanness as they pass through these
ordeals developed as an equation between
them and their situation what does this
mean
genuine authentic Humanity is not just
something that we possess as our nature
and have to like Preserve
it's also something that arises out of
us in our engagement with the world
particularly with suffering and also In
our relation to others
so it's not something we can simply take
for granted oh I'm totally human we
become human existentially you could say
he goes on and he says possibly the
difference between what I call the
Android mentality and the human is that
the latter passed through something the
former did not or at least pass through
it and responded differently changed
altered what it did and hence what it is
it became I sense the Android repeating
over and over again the same limited
reflex gesture like an insect raising
its wings threateningly over and over
again or emitting a bad smell one
defense response works or it doesn't
caught inside in trouble the organism
that is made more human that becomes
precisely at that moment human wrestles
deep within itself and out of itself to
find one response after another as each
fails right and so this is a very uh
pregnant idea you could say right
um and so you know he talks about a
number of other aspects of of things and
I think that you know it's great to
close with this last uh bit that he's
he's talking about right this uh
inability for a computer to process uh
paradoxes he says
um
he's using this you know in the end was
the beginning right and he says perhaps
when a computer is ready to churn forth
one or on the other of the two
statements in an Android operating the
computer will make a decision although
if I'm correct about the Android
mentality it will be unable to decide
and will print out both at once creating
a self-canceling nothing which will not
even serve as a primordial chaos and
Android might however be able to handle
this capable of some sort of
decision-making power it might
conceivably pick one statement or the
other is quote correct but no Android
and you will recall and mean realize I
mean by this term I'm summing up that
which is not human no Android would
think to do with a bright-eyed little
girl I know did something a little
bizarre certainly ethically questionable
uh but to me truly human and then it
shows a spirit of Mary Defiance a
spirited though not spiritual bravery
and uniqueness and this involves
stealing Coca-Cola for her friends
so you know dick is providing us with
some very thoughtful and well reflected
upon ways in which we could understand
the differentiation between the Android
and the human there's a risk for us
human beings of becoming Androids
because of the situations that we're in
including how we deal with Androids and
human beings that have become
androidized and we see that coming up
particularly in Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep you know there's a bounty
hunter who Phil rash
seems to himself be going down that line
as Deckard recognizes right and so
there's there's a lot here to unpack but
now we should actually talk about the
Androids in these novels at least to
some extent
given what dick has told us about the
distinction that he wants to maintain
between human beings and Androids one
that is in danger of being effaced and
not just by outside forces but even in
some cases human beings allowing
themselves or making the wrong choices
and becoming more and more like reflex
machines insects Androids it's
interesting to think of the characters
or in some cases not quite characters
but things involved in these three
novels and if we start with the
simulacra right so we've got this uh
discussion this is very early on
the cob flush the cob flesh is the name
of the simulacrum simulacrum stopped its
arms struck at stuck out rigid in their
final gesture the withered face vacuous
the simulacrum said nothing and
automatically the TV cameras also shut
off one by one there was no longer for
any anything for them to transmit and
the technicians knew it they've got the
message across right and then these
characters are talking about how to deal
with the seemingly fascist sons of job
right and uh they're then going to talk
about building the next simulacrum right
McRae says cold flash is going to go
soon within the next month he didn't say
what carpet once wanted him to say
um will we build the next simulacrum
carp would have asked had he dared but
he was afraid to speak karp was as McRae
knewick Howard his Integrity had long
ago been emasculated in order to he be
capable of functioning properly within
the German business Community spiritual
moral emasculation was a present-day
prerequisite for participation in the
gay class those who are in on the
secrets in the ruling circles
and we go on a little bit further right
so he says the next firm which built a
Similac from the government of the USDA
would be a small firm one which the
authorities could control the name which
came to mcrae's mind was Frau and Zimmer
Associates an extremely small marginal
firm barely surviving in the world of
simcom simulacra construction for
planetary colonization he did not tell
Anton karp this but he intended to open
business discussions with Maurice frauin
Zimmer the head of the firm any day now
right so there's this whole discussion
here and the similar Akram is just a
tool it's just there sort of like the
teaching machines in Martian time slip
when we go on to the Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep the Similac or the
Androids are they have considerably more
agency they are much closer to us humans
they are mobile they have memories they
present themselves they take the place
of other human beings and they even have
a fake police station and that's where
we're going to go I'm not going to try
to summarize every human Android
interaction in this amazing novel but
let's just look at a few that give us a
taste of what's going on
so deck art
who is a human is trying to kill Luba
Luft he has to give her a void Camp test
which tells empathetic responses first
and she calls the cops and cops come
arrest him and they take him to a police
station which is itself a similacrum
it's a fake police station
and Garland is one of the people on Deck
Arts list he's supposed to kill these
different Nexus 6 Androids and Phil Rush
is sent upstairs
and he's another Bounty Hunter and then
Garland says you know I'm warning you
you're not going to like the results of
these tests and Phil Rush goes upstairs
and you know Garland has a laser tube on
him and he says that damn fool rash
Deckard says he actually doesn't know he
doesn't know he doesn't back she doesn't
have the slightest idea otherwise he
couldn't live out a life as a bounty
hunter a human occupation hardly an
Android occupation so Garland is saying
listen I'm an Android so is that guy
Phil rash and that poor sap doesn't know
that he is an Android yet and he says
these these other carbons the other
suspects you're supposed to test and
retire I know them all we all came here
together on the same ship from Mars not
rush he stayed behind another week
receiving the synthetic memory system
and then Rick says what will he do when
he finds out
I don't have the foggiest idea Garland
said remotely it ought from an abstract
intellectual Viewpoint to be interesting
he may kill me kill himself maybe you
too he may kill everyone he can human
and Android alike I understand such
things happen when there's been a
synthetic memory system laid down when
one thinks it's human right and he goes
on
um and you know they talk a little bit
more and Garland brings up something
really Central to uh Androids and
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep he
said Rick says you Androids don't
exactly cover for each other in times of
stress Garland says back I think you're
right it would seem we lack a specific
Talent you humans possess I believe it's
called empathy right and as it turns out
um Phil rash is going to be
tested by
um
Deckard but the reason is first when
they go to get Luba Luft
um
Phil rash is ready to kill her and she
suggests to him that he's actually an
Android himself Phil Rush is also very
worried he's like oh I've got a pet you
know a pet squirrel the Androids
actually have pets I care about that
squirrel so they get a little bit lift
right and
um Deckard actually does something very
nice for level he buys her a book that
has you know artwork that that she would
be you know interested in
um so anyway Louisville says to Resh
you're not human no more than I am
you're an Android too and Phil rush says
we'll deal with that at the proper time
let's take her to my car see Androids
will kill each other right Androids
don't feel a sense of solidarity they
are essentially self-contained machines
and they they do end up killing a little
bit Luft and then Phil himself is going
to get the void Camp test Deckard is
going to administer it to him and Phil
rush says if I test out Android you'll
undergo renewed faith in the human race
but because it's not going to work out
that way I suggest you begin framing an
ideology which will account for it and
then after the test it turns out that
rash is human
how does this work what's what's going
on here
so Rick says there's a defect in your
empathetic role-taking ability one that
we don't test for your feelings towards
Androids
and rush says well of course we don't
test for that we're killing Androids and
then decorate says well maybe we should
he never thought of it before and never
felt any empathy on his own part towards
the Androids he killed always he'd
assume that throughout his psyche he'd
experienced the Android as a clever
machine as in his conscious View and yet
in contrast to Phil rash a difference
had manifested itself and he felt
instinctively he was right empathy
towards an artificial construct he asked
himself something that only pretends to
be alive but Louisville looked seemed
genuinely alive it had not worn the
aspect of a simulation
Phil rash says you realize what this
would do if we included Androids in the
our range of empathetic identification
as we do animals we couldn't protect
ourselves these Nexus 6 types that roll
over us and mash us flat you and I all
the bounty hunters We Stand between the
Nexus 6 and Mankind a barrier which
keeps the two distinct furthermore I
thought the test was over and then Rick
says
I want to ask myself a question I'm
going to show you how to do the test
and we're going to ask me a question
and
what happens he realizes that he has an
emphatically empathetic response except
it has to do with Androids Rick says I'm
capable of feeling empathy for at least
specific certain Androids not for all of
them but one or two for Lobel Luft as an
example uh so I was wrong there's
nothing unnatural or unhuman about Phil
rash's reactions it's me
and then Phil Rush actually says
wow you're really in a bad spot Deckard
and uh Rick says well what should I do
and then Phil rush says it's actually
sex
it it she was physically attractive
hasn't that ever happened to you before
we were taught it constitutes a prime
problem in bounty hunting don't you know
that in the colonies they have Android
Mistresses and so that's you know
perhaps a possible explanation the sex
attraction and drive produces empathy
and we see this happening as Rick has an
affair cheating on his wife with Rachel
Rosen they have sex and then she tells
him she reveals to him something
she says um
well he says this is my end he said to
himself as a bounty hunter after the
babies there won't be any more not after
this tonight Rachel says you look so sad
and she says you're not going to be able
to hunt Androids any longer so don't
look sad please and she goes on no
Bounty Hunter has ever gone on after
being with me except one a very cynical
man Phil rash and he's nutty he works
out in left field on his own
um and so you know she she's telling him
about all of this and he asks well how
many times have you done this she says I
don't remember seven or eight no I
believe it's nine yes nine times you
know so essentially she has
um ruined him for bounty hunting as as
it turns out that's not actually the
case and he resolves uh to kill her but
doesn't kill her right and
um lets her her go she's actually going
to do something terrible kill his
electric or not electric his real uh
goat uh throw it off the building
because of her lack of empathy but he
goes on and is able to kill the
remaining bounties he's actually going
to be aided by Mercer this figure that
gets left out in the movie but plays it
incredibly important role in the book
who turns out to be both fake and real
at the same time and is oriented around
empathy
so in in uh the Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep the Androids are in
general bad
incapable of empathy but it's possible
for human beings Rick Deckard and also
Isidore to feel empathy towards them
when we look at we can build you which
is an earlier novel
it's a little bit different with the
Androids or similacra in this case it's
actually the humans that are more
Android like for example Chris the young
woman
and I'm going to read this this uh
little selection here what bothered Mori
most with it was that his daughter Priss
somewhere along the line and lost her
sense of humor instead of being giggly
and silly and sloppy as she'd once been
she had become as precise as a
calculator not only that once she'd
cared about animals and then during her
stay at Kansas City when she's in the
psychiatric Institute
she'd suddenly gotten so she couldn't
stand a dog or cat she'd gone on with
her interest in chemistry however and
they had a profession seemed to him a
good thing
he's asked has the Outpatient Therapy
there helped her it keeps her at a
stable level she doesn't slide back she
still has a strong hypochondriacal Trend
and she still washes her hand a lot
she'll never stop that and she's over
precise and withdrawn I can tell you
what they call it schizoid personality
and so this winds up being you know her
being essentially like the Android but
then they start building Androids right
they build the Stanton first and the
Androids interestingly
have a kind of uh capacity for empathy
and caring
um
so
there's there's a conversation that's
going on here between Louis Rosen right
and the Stanton where he says I'd like
to ask you a question sir doesn't it
seem odd to you that though you were
born in 1800 you're still alive in 1982
doesn't it seem odd to you to be shut
off every now and then and what about
your being made out of transistors and
relays you didn't used to be because in
1800 they didn't have transistors and
relays I paused waiting
yes Stanton agreed those are Oddities I
have here a volume he held up a book
which deals with the new science of
cybernetics and this science has shed
light on my perplexity
that excited me your perplexity
yes sir during my stay with your father
I discussed I discussed puzzling matters
of this nature with him when I consider
the brief span of my life swallowed up
in the eternity before and behind it the
small space that I fill or even see
engulfed in the immediate immensity of
spaces which I know not which no not me
I am afraid I should think so I said I
am afraid sir and wonder to see myself
here rather than there for there is no
reason why I should be here rather than
there now rather than then
did you come to any conclusion he's
asking him what what's your take on all
of this right
the Stanton cleared its throat then got
out a folded linen handkerchief and
carefully blew its nose
it seems to me that time must move in
strange jumps passing over intervening
epox but why it would do that or even
how I do not know at a certain point the
Mind cannot fathom anything further
and then Rosen says you want to hear my
theory yes sir
I claim there is no Edwin M Stanton or
Lewis Rosen anymore there was once but
they're dead were machines
the Stanton regarded me it's round
wrinkled face twisted up there may be
some truth in that
and I said more Iraq and Fri and Chris
Frau and Zimmer designed us and Bob
Bundy built us and right now they're
working on an Abe Lincoln symbolacrum
right and so they go on from there so
these these machines are capable of
processing the thought that they are
machines and yet
entities
later on
um they're going to talk uh to to
Lincoln right or the Lincoln better uh
put right
and uh the Lincoln says
would you tell me sir what a man is yes
I would Barrow said he caught blanc's
eye a man is a forked radish is that
definition familiar to you Mr Lincoln
yes sir it is the simulacrum said
Shakespeare as his false staff speak
that does he not right Barrow said and
I'd add to that a man can be defined as
an animal who carries a pocket
handkerchief how about that Mr
Shakespeare didn't say that what's going
on there they're confronting the machine
the thinking machine with paradoxes with
crazy talk right
no sir the samal Akram agreed he did not
I appreciate your humor Mr barrows may I
use that remark in a speech and he says
thank you the simulacrum said now you've
defined a man as an animal which carries
a pocket handkerchief but what is an
animal
I can tell you you're not Barrow said
his hands at his trouser Pockets an
animal has a biological Heritage and
makeup which you lack you've got valves
and wires and switches you're a machine
you're like a a spinning jenny like a
steam engine can a steam engine consider
itself entitled to protection under the
claws of the Constitution which you
quoted has it got a right to eat the
bread it produces like a man the symbol
Akron so I could have machine talk sure
radios phonographs tape recorders
telephones they all Yak away like mad
the simulacrum considered it did not
know what these were but it could make
assured guess it had enough time by
itself to do a great deal of thinking
then what sir is a machine the
simulacrum asked you're one these
fellows made you you belong to them the
long line dark bearded face Twisted with
weary Amusement as the similacrum gazed
down at barrows well then you sir to our
a machine for you have a Creator too and
like these fellows he made you in His
image I believe Spinoza the great Hebrew
scholar held that opinion regarding
animals that they were clever machines
the critical think thing I think is the
soul a machine can do anything a man can
you'll agree to that but it doesn't have
a soul there is no soul said barrows
that's Pap while then the simulacrum
said a machine is the same as an animal
it went on slowly in its dry patient way
and an animal is the same as a man is
that not correct so he's arguing this
simulacrum this Android about the nature
of humanity right and whether humans are
machines there is one other passage in
here regarding the Lincoln that I want
to bring up
Lincoln was exactly like me Lincoln had
taken everything hard he might have been
remote but he was not dead emotionally
quite the contrary he was the opposite
of pris of the cold schizoid type grief
emotional empathy were written on his
faith he fully felt the Sorrows of the
war every single death so it was hard to
believe that what that what the
Britannica called his remoteness was a
sign of schizophrenia the same with his
well-known indecision and in addition I
had my own personal experience with him
or to be more exact with his simulacrum
I didn't catch the alienness the
otherness with a similacrum that I had
caught with pris I had a natural trust
and liking for Lincoln and that was
exact that was certainly the opposite to
what I felt towards press there was
something innately good and warm and
human about him a vulnerability and I
knew from my own experience with pris
that the schizoid was not vulnerable he
was withdrawn to safety to a point where
he could serve other humans could watch
them in a scientific manner without
jeopardizing himself
he goes on and he says that Lincoln knew
the paradoxes of the human soul it's
great Parts it's weak Parts it's lusts
its nobility all the odd-shaped pieces
that went to make it up in its almost
infinite variety he had bummed around
um and you know so what is he saying
here Lincoln the Lincoln simulacrum the
Lincoln Android
is if not authentically human certainly
approaching it so we have a very
interesting set of possible approaches
and depictions of what it means to be an
Android and what it means to be human
in these three novels and they don't all
match up to each other do they so that's
well worth considering as a major
philosophical theme running throughout
these works and indeed throughout Philip
K Dick's larger body of work and his
thought as a whole
there is a clear priority when it comes
to the novels in which Androids play a
central role that Philip K dick is going
to accord or assign to Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep the simulacra and we
can build you both very interesting
um you know in some respects adding
aspects of the Android that aren't quite
there into Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep but the Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep is going to get more
central place in Dick's own thinking
about his work and it doesn't just stem
from the fact that the Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep is the one novel that
is selected for a film adaptation into
the Blade Runner which we're going to
talk a little bit about later on in part
because dick has a lot to say about
what's going on with that that's quite
revealing and in part because we also
want to point out some of the things
that are there in the movie that are not
there in the novel and vice versa but
it's not just the novel
Philip K dick we have this book called
The exegesis and this was edited by
these these two Pamela Jackson and
Jonathan let them out of a whole slew of
papers thousands of pages of things that
dick was writing sort of making sense
out of his own
um as he viewed it mystical experience
and what it meant and the works that he
had written now a lot of this is from
the 1970s a little bit I believe from
the yeah 1980s shortly before Dick
himself passed away
but um the novels that we're talking
about for the most part are written in
the 60s and 70s right A lot of them
written in the 1960s so he's had a lot
of time to think about all of this and
the first really important entry that
has to do with Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep is in folder 18 just
listed as August 1978 or later so we're
talking about 10 years after the
publication of Do Androids Dream of
Electric Sheep and he starts out by
talking about the three Stigmata of
Palmer Eldridge and Maze of Death and he
says their total opposites in May's
reality is a hallucination there's a
real world behind it in three Stigmata
hallucination becomes real not real
becomes hallucination in less departs
and then immediately he starts talking
about to Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep and he says
surface level
or to Android's dream reveals number one
surface level Mercer is real now Mercer
is not an Android Mercer is the thing
the Androids can't quite get right below
that too Mercer is fake a hoax a fraud
Androids can get that because they think
that he is just a fake and they're going
to show it and then that'll be the end
of mercerism and then third below that
Mercer real bottom line and he says I
think this three-level structure is the
one that we have vis-a-vis Christianity
a secret within a secret
a not a a precious artifact three layer
was close you have this question is fake
fake real with respect to Christianity
yes this is in terms of a two value
system a or not a if a three value
system is used a becomes not a by
reversal then not a is reversed not
restoring a
but something else a what how does it
differ from a if at all answer call it a
prime I say a prime out A's a in an
ontological sense it is profoundly
deeper newer richer level than a but
also paradoxically it is a but a prime
is not a so a prime is and is not a and
he goes on from that so this is telling
us something about the
you know the hoax
mercerism in the novel which plays such
an important role for Decker in making
sense out of his
experiences
and his relation to Androids and also to
uh human beings
a little bit later on he's going to put
a whole bunch of novels into
a sequence with each other
and he begins first by talking about
um a listing of this the logical
sequence scanner so you know Scanner
Darkly occlusion tears what is really
there which we don't see the flow my
tears the policeman said Stigmata who
includes us at spurious worlds maze how
occluded negative hallucinations finally
ubik The salvific Entity and how it
works notice that the Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep is it hasn't been
mentioned yet nor are either of these
two Android novels being mentioned and
he goes on and he talks about this
Sinister life form taking power over us
reducing us to Slaves it causes us to
forget our former State and be unable to
see or to think straight and not to know
we can't see or think straight finally
it becomes invisible To Us by reason of
what it has done to us we cannot even
monitor our own deformity our own
impairment so going on with this
he tells us that scanner as I've said
before is the other half of Tears the
inner half and then he goes on and talks
about the various books were written in
the wrong order but
they can be read in the right order or
anyhow gestalted if read they will be
gestalted what's the correct sequence
Scanner Darkly one of his later novels
right
flow my tears the policeman said
Stigmata through Stigmata Palmer
Eldritch
maze maze of death ubik and then number
six
do Android stream of Electric Sheep and
he says a vital theme that of Mercer and
his reality through some sort of Mystic
identification via empathy the role of
animals the tomb world the fakeness of
fakeness my two-slit logic and then he
goes on to talk about a short story
which has been turned into a movie as
well imposter
then he talks about faith of and then he
says every other relevant story and
novel from joint to remember wholesale
to Electric ant Retreat syndrome not
listed in one through eight which you
know could include these two as well but
what this shows us very interestingly is
that as dick is making sense out of his
works
and as he's thinking about what his
Works have to reveal to us to Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep is not just some
cool adventure story or you know about
the Master Slave dialectic or anything
like that
it is coming after these other novels
where the question of reality and
fakeness or reality and lies are
actually being raised again he actually
comes up with another list on a
subsequent page saying okay scanner
tears Stigmata maze ubik Androids coming
number six again after all of these and
he ties uh Maze ubik and Androids
together in salvific entity
mysteriously here right so you know this
is quite interesting a little bit later
as he's playing with similar themes
he's going to tell us that I now see our
fallen State as consisting of four basic
deformations number one ear real world
which we accept is Real This Cuts us off
from the truly real world
number two perceptual occlusion which
prevents us from accurate reality
testing so that we ourselves reinforce
the convincingness of the unreal world
number three pervasive deterministic
enslavement which reduces us to the
level of reflex machines lacking true
volition which is part of the problem
for the Androids isn't it but also for
the schizoid personality the person who
has been become androidized right
finally fourth Amnesia which Cuts us off
from our true memory systems which in
turn robs us of our authentic identities
and he says who gains by this what is
the payoff and to whom right so you know
this is uh showing that there's there's
something uh important epistemologically
going on here in all of his novels
um he turns to discussing
specifically
what it is that this entity that's
revealing things to him zebra is is is
doing and he says
this is uh in section 2122 this all goes
back to what I figured out before it is
the ear reel versus the real the
inauthentic versus the authentic that
which is being in contrast to that which
only seems so to me it is epistemology
which is involved rootedness and Truth
versus the LIE
throughout all of my writing there is a
preoccupation with Fakes and the fake
fake worlds fake humans fake objects
fake time Etc you authentically the
authentic human versus the Android or
reflex machine is the essence of it
again and again I attempt to formulate
criteria for what is fake and what is
not fake in every area from a comic book
to a world leader to a girlfriend to an
entire universe things are seldom what
they seem right
it has to do with reality testing which
is related to another theme of mine
mental illness which brings in
hallucinations and deliberate deception
now here
what is he talking about the penultimate
truth
the simulacra
game players of Titan Etc novels I
usually Overlook and mental illness
brings in Martian time slip Dr Blood
Money the simulacra again clans of the
Alpine Moon so virtually all of my
writing interlocks at this substratum
and then he says I count
21 books
including story collections in which
fake versus real is in some way the
topic 22 if japed is included plus a
number of
unanthologized stories in Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep for instance
fake versus real operates on five levels
this is again dick reflecting on his own
work what are these five levels
fake synthetic moods electronically
generated beginning the novel with that
right with the mood organ
two fake animals machines Electric Sheep
uh three fake Androids uh fake humans
Androids including fake memories and
identities
four
fake savior Mercer as he points out is
an old wino movie bit player and then
finally again something that's left out
of the you know Blade Runner fake police
station
part of the world and he says
um in uh
um TMI THC they're deliberately faked
objects in a world this is the man in
the High Castle uh the totality of which
may be fake in which the access won
World War II and fake fakes bring up my
double flip-flop to Slit logic is a fake
fake more fake than a just a fake or a
null fake here probability Theory enters
logic not perception and again he goes
back to fake World fake perceptions fake
volition fake memories and then he says
all of this is turned into the real by
zebra this entity that he thinks he's
experienced the Holy Spirit who isn't
really the Holy Spirit but Christ who is
really God the Creator who masquerades
itself as objects info and Casual
processes and finally as mere humans so
to Android's Dream of Electric Sheep and
to a certain extent the simulacra now
are caught up in this very complex
epistemological set of Reflections on
fakes and on how we transform the fake
into the real
again you know showing that this is a
very Central set of ideas
he talks also about the Blade Runner
movie and he says that um
a strange and mysterious strategy to put
the new carrigma the you know good news
into a novel published in the late 60s
but then disclosed to me only now toward
the end of 1981 but just at the time we
get the signed contract or the Blade
Runner people to re-release the novel in
conjunction with the film as if the
valus trilogy has diverted everyone's
attention my own included like when the
thought came to me that the true message
was in Frozen journey and not in Dallas
now notice what he says here
the true message is not in vallus but it
is I now think
in Androids
and it will have the greatest
circulation probably of all viewed in
terms of God's strategy Blade Runner has
been used as a means to the end the end
being the kerygma in Androids
thus to have suppressed Androids and
either written or authorized the
novelization based on the screenplay
would have been to hand over Victory to
evil but this did not happen the fully
executed contract between Blade Runner
and me regarding the re-release of
Androids was waiting for me in my post
office box on Friday the day I was up in
Venice and learned the truth
to share experience The Joy by the
godhead as it invades expands into the
animal kingdom lost to it these many
Millennia the repair to the damage God
had yet yes it is a self-repair or
re-inhaling a recovery of part of its
lost self Christ re-knitting the
decomposing Cosmos and restoring it to
God Christ moves lower and lower deeper
and deeper into the decomposing Cosmos
down layer by layer starting with the
man thus the vision of Christ at and in
the trash layer is a vision of ultimate
and final repair now that's a very
interesting thing to say isn't it so
somehow
by writing
and then having turned into a film and
then deciding to re-release to Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep Philip K dick
thinks that something is being fixed and
there's a parallelism to how Mercer
descends into the tomb world the world
of decay of death of kipple entropy and
then arises out of it christ-like as
well
the last entry that I'm going to read
here is from uh very uh late in the book
right
and he's bringing up um
uh vallis again and
um you know uh this this Vision that he
has about Christ being the biosphere
itself the primordial Garden that man as
a species has broken away from and
turned against destroying it exploiting
it now
what happened in the beginning of the
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep the
back story is we have
broken the biosphere that's why animals
are so rare right uh and we did so
through some sort of you know nuclear
war that that had all these these uh
bad effects going on and he goes out and
he says once Christ is homologized to
the biosphere the nature of original sin
is clear and with it the nature of the
fall into hell endless horizontal
tracking and occlusion thus a coherent
and Lucid system emerges and it is this
that oddly really in parentheses is
dealt with in Androids into Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep
the cruelty to the spider is
paradigmatic of the evil act committed
by a debased and in fact soulless
pseudo-human creature against God
himself and symbolizes and expresses the
total issue hence logically the figure
of Mercer his ability to restore life
and the empathy Factor itself a fortiori
what debased parentheses Androids man
does now against the biosphere is only
the final and ultimate act or step that
completes the series of Falls that began
with original sin and expulsion from the
garden that is true extinct Cosmos note
extinct as in Androids the e-entry in
the Guinness Animal book
so very clearly to Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep is not just a cool story
about you know zapping robots and and
humans fighting each other it's not just
a love story as a matter of fact that's
more in the the movie than in the actual
book
it's not simply about empathy
um it's not just a story of you know
colonization or anything like that dick
thinks that it is really Central
to the entire life work that he had
going on and the contrast between
Androids and humans and the vital role
that empathy is going to play is
absolutely Central in that in that
epistemological and ethical and
metaphysical problem one of the topics
that becomes absolutely unavoidable to
go into when we think about Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep is its
adaptation to the movie The Blade Runner
and there's several different things
that we have from Philip K dick that
give us some additional insight about
this one of these is the notes on do
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep In
which he is you know sort of thinking
about what a good film adaptation would
look like and then the other would be
um from it's not a actually the very
last interview it's found in this this
book the last interview and other
conversations which is uh discussing
the film adaptation Blade Runner in
Hollywood Temptations an interview by
James Van hiss and before we launch into
either of these we should point out that
I think a lot of people know because
they've read the book and they've also
watched the movie they're both you know
very successful compositions but they
and they are connected together in terms
of characters and plot to a certain
extent and setting to a certain extent
but there are some very important
differences as well and a lot of these
have to do
with what got left out so for example
the entire religion of mercerism where
um you know you've got this empathy box
and it's importance for human beings you
can also say that the the notion of
empathy doesn't figure as heavily in the
Blade Runner as it does in Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep where it's
absolutely Central and the Voigt Camp
test is based primarily on apathetic
responses
the motivation of the the characters who
are the Androids changes significantly
pris is supposed to be the same model as
Rachel Rosen obviously or they're played
by two different characters or two
different actors so they don't look the
same in that and there's a lot of other
things we could point out as well that
are fundamentally different I think that
one of the biggest
important differences is the lack
of the fake police station that plays a
major role in the middle of the novel
and you could also say there's less
emphasis on the importance of animals
and animal life as well so those are all
some really important things to
highlight first let's actually look
because it's earlier in time at
what dick himself kind of envisioned and
the the first question that he begins
with is who is the Viewpoint character
who are we going to use and he notes
that in his novel he's basically got two
Viewpoint characters he says it has to
be either the Bounty Hunter Rick Deckard
or Jack Isadore and it's very
interesting what he says here
is younger were he to be the Viewpoint
character we would perhaps something
have we'd have something on the order of
the graduate a movie that isn't sci-fi
at all right in which everybody over 30
is corrupt in an instrument of the
establishment and young free innocent
love wins out and then he he dick says
an oddly Corner corny theme for such a
supposedly adult movie and the novel
Isadore has a naive love directed
towards the Androids Rick deckard's
views the Androids or vicious machines
that must be destroyed these two
different and mutually exclusive views
running parallel to each other in a twin
plot scheme merged toward the ends of
the work when Isidore is confronted by
the cruelty of the Androids as they cut
the legs off the spiders and then he
says so you know I don't know that we
want to have Isidore as the main
Viewpoint character and then he says if
Rick Deckard is the protagonist we're
faced with a a difficult problem the
love that the Bounty Hunter feels
towards animals in contrast to his
heartless murders of the Androids to
love an animal more than a person is a
deranged or cynical view or so it might
seem we must learn very soon why Rick
holds this view which means an early
proof for his view contrasted with
Isidore or is this not the major theme
the struggle between the two views with
proof only at the end that Rick
deckard's view was correct
now notice what he says here in the
novel we are told that Androids lack
human feeling warmth and empathetic
sensitivity
but we're not shown this in action until
the meeting of Isadora and Deckard but
maybe this is a good way to handle it
the contrast between Isidore and his
views in contrast to Deckard and his
views in in some way as the primary
story and he says notice I say story and
not theme the theme of the book tends to
Cluster around the religion of mercerism
and its emphasis on shared pain and
mutual compassion compassion a rebirth
of the primordial Christian view
or is the basic theme the broad
background the total World in which they
live with their Collective and general
worship of animals the decaying huge
apartment buildings and the specials
plus the running thread of mutual
empathy so he's reflecting on what is
this novel really about and are the
Androids as bad as they seem and the
answer is of course yes
then he goes on and he starts thinking
about well who would we cast for this
and and it's interesting because none of
these people get cast right Rick Deckard
could be played by Gregory Peck which
makes him powerful and sensitive and
wise in contract to Richard Widmark
which makes him a psychotic killer with
several lesser possibilities like Martin
Balsam which makes him into an
archetypal Father Figure someone like
Ben gazara which makes him bold and a
man of action what about Isidore he
could be played for example by Dean
Stockwell which makes him sensitive and
an introvert living in a lonely world of
his own making or perhaps Wally Cox
which makes him into Wally Cox my theory
calls for Decker to be the protagonist
um and so I would really favor somebody
like Gregory Peck to play Rick Deckard
and Steen stock will pay Isador play
Isidore and then who should play Rachel
Rosen who does he suggest a vibrant hard
girl such as Grace Slick a bit of
casting I would really plug for right
and then he says this has to uh we have
to pay attention to tone right this is a
touching story
and uh is it is it a touching story or
gun play action or a broad General
picture of a whole an entire world that
is ethnic fundamentally with many quaint
and odd Customs practiced with solemnity
by the natives custom that include
murder on a legal basis people that is
the Androids without any legal rights of
any sort he said the film could be
anti-cop or pro cop uh and what age
group are we going to pick
um he also brings up you know the two
Rachel's which is going to disappear as
we know in the Blade Runner the small
plot element He says of the other police
station could be eliminated entirely so
he's already
starting to think past that the mood
organ material he says yeah we could
probably get rid of that as well maybe
that's not quite so important and and
then he goes on and he says it seems to
me the one strong point of the novel is
the fact that it provides space for many
moods and tones there is the dramatic
search and destruction of the Androids
the tenderness felt towards live animals
the weird deserted apartment building in
which Jack Isidore lives opportunities
for humor The Peculiar the very
frightening and of course the oau felt
when Mercer is encountered we we can
have a many-sided film or I would think
some of the moods and plot can be
eliminated entirely however important
they are to the novel and then remaining
elements can be retained and built up
more
what is one of those remaining elements
the Mercer theme right he also talks
about sex there could be room for more
sex for example Rick Deckard making love
to Rachel then dissolved to Isidore
trying the same on his racial Android
and following it all up a la Peter
Sellers one of the greatest comedic
actors of the you know middle 20th
century
um and you know so this is an
interesting idea he says it brings up
the whole underlying subject sexual
relations between humans and Androids
what is it like what does it mean is it
for instance like going to bed with a
real woman or is it an awful nightmarish
bad trip or what is dead and inert seems
alive and warm and capable of the most
acute intimacy known to living creatures
and then he says something quite
profound here
isn't this the sexual Union between Rick
Deckard and Rachel Rosen isn't it the
Summa of falsity and mechanical motions
carried out minus any real feeling as we
understand the word feeling on each of
their parts does in fact her mental and
physical coldness numb the male the
human man into an echo of it and he says
that
um you know this is uh talked about in
the novel this is the extent of the
subject is handled in the novel but
there are more possibilities which might
come out vividly in a film version for
example is this a way he can cheat
vis-a-vis his wife Iran who by the way
gets left out in the movie right
um
uh it doesn't count doesn't it count
right is it all right to sleep with an
Android
um
Rachel asks in the book would you ever
go to bed with an Android again and his
his answer is if it was a girl if she
resembled you but Rachel's already made
the point she's not a person she's a
type a sub form of Androids in general
his relationship by having intercourse
with her has melded him to not an
individual human or Android but to a
whole type or model
and uh which theoretically there could
be tens of thousands to whom then has he
really given his erratic libido too
right and so he says here I think the
crucial questions of what is reality and
what does illusion come up strongly the
whole sexual scene with Rachel and the
one between prison Isidore could be
dreamlike but not in the usual sense
right it could be a horrifying
mechanical episode of half dream half
reality and so he's got a lot of
interesting Reflections there on what
this would would be like in a movie what
does he have to say about the actual
film dramatization so there were
actually two you could call them
attempts to adapt it and in this
interview with van hease he says years
and years ago there was an attempt to
adapt to Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep Martin Scorsese Jay Cox are both
interested but they didn't option at
this is the first movie interest in any
property of mine then herb Jaffe
optioned it and Robert Jaffe did a
screenplay back in about 1973 so quite a
long time before the the Blade Runner
actually comes out and Dick says the
screenplay was sent to me it was so
crude I didn't understand it was
actually the shooting script I thought
it was the rough I wrote them and asked
them if they would like me to do the
shooting script
at which point Robert Jaffe flew down
here and confessed he'd written it under
a gnome to plume I said to him then it
was so bad I wanted to know if he wanted
me to beat him up at the airport or wait
till he got to my apartment and Dick
said all I ask is you do not drag me
down to ruin with you and then then he
says well what was wrong with the
screenplay and Dick says
what he had done is take the novel and
turned it into a comedy a spoof along
the lines of get smart right so it was
it was pretty bad right and dick then
felt that he'd been burned by Hollywood
and um then you know Ridley Scott uh and
his screenwriter Hampton uh Fancher
approached him well there's still an
option on it and they they get it back
right and interestingly
um dick is not like a super fan of
Ridley Scott at the time there's this
interesting line here I criticized
Ridley Scott's picture alien saying a
monster is a monster and a spaceship is
a spaceship and it got by on special
effects because it had no new ideas
right and
um he had a friend who said anything you
write we can create these guys don't go
on story anymore they go on special
effects and he says this is exactly what
I was saying about the original
screenplay of Blade Runner they were
going with squishing people's heads and
people's arms and legs coming off they
wanted to do what they'd done an alien
and he said this is what I thought of
the screenplay until David people's got
a hold of it and did a new version
my agent said well they must have gone
back to the book and indeed they did go
back to the book so it's coherent in
relation to the book and then he said
now what we have is the beautiful result
that Ridley Scott who is a visual
graphic director who does not go in for
storyline but is of the new school who
goes on goes on in for dramatic visual
effects is yoked to a coherent storyline
it has subtle nuances that are very good
and it appeals not just to the dramatic
though it is very dramatic but it
appeals to the intellect there's some
tender parts there's some intelligent
Parts it's a very mature and
sophisticated screenplay and they did
use it
and then
um he he also uh talks about how the you
know the portrayal of the Androids and
their motivation had changed a bit right
they're infiltrating tyrol's industrial
complex but the motivation that people's
assigned is rather lofty he accentuates
their very limited lifespan and their
desire to meet their Creator God in
order to find some way to overcome their
limited lifespan
um and then uh they go on a little bit
more and
um
dick says
um
a little bit later on here we go that uh
what did you think of the casting
so dick says Sean Young who plays Rachel
I've never seen act I've seen Harrison
Ford act and Rutger Hauer act but I've
never seen her act I guess hardly
anyone's seen her act but when I came to
these pictures I was blown away I said
that's Rachel you could have hung
pictures of a hundred different women
and I could have unerringly picked out
that one as Rachel that's not a
simulation of Rachel that is Rachel they
went and found her and I told my friends
that I want to be introduced to her and
they said no you don't you've got it
backwards you don't want to be
introduced to her
um you know and then there's there's
more and more that goes on with us and
then he's asked about Rutger Hower who
of course plays Roy Beatty right and he
says well you know I saw him in soldier
of orange he'd kill you just as soon as
look at you oh my God this is the Nordic
Superman that Hitler would have said
would come marching out of the
laboratory this is the blonde Beast the
Nazis were creating and of course the
origin of the book Aunt dandroid's Dream
of Electric Sheep was my research into
the Nazis for the man in the High Castle
he talks about you know looking through
these gestapo documents and the issue of
lack of empathy
a sort of androidization on the part of
the Gestapo officers he says I read this
line we are kept awake at night by the
cries of starving children I remember
that line and it influenced me I thought
there's amongst us something that is a
bipedal humanoid morphologically
identical to the human being but that is
not human it is not human to complain in
your diary that starving children are
keeping you in the way awake and there
in the 1940s was born my idea that
within our species is a bifurcation a
dichotomy between the truly human and
that which mimics the truly human when I
saw those stills of Rutger Hower I
thought holy Jesus it's come back right
a little bit later on he says that um
you know this this idea of the owning a
real animal has been really pushed into
the background the symbolism of the live
animal versus the artificial animal is
gone the metaphor is gone but the basic
theme of the novel The Two basic themes
that interweave are there the first is
that is what can constitutes the
essential human being and how do we
distinguish and Define the essential
human being from that which only
masquerades as human that's there
the second theme
is the tragic theme that if you fight
evil you will wind up becoming evil and
that this is the condition of life
there's a quote from the novel that I
think really is the basic theme of the
novel it doesn't appear in the film
because it's spoken by Mercer a
character in the book who wasn't
transferred over to the film here's the
line
you will be required to do wrong no
matter where you go it is the basic
condition of life to be required to
violate your own identity at some time
every creature which lives must do so it
is the ultimate Shadow the defeat of
creation this is the curse at work the
curse that feeds on all life everywhere
in the universe and Nick goes on to say
that is really the intellectual theme of
the novel that Decker to kill the
replicants or the Androids or whatever
you want to call them is brutalized and
dehumanized and he goes on he says so
you have Deckard becoming more and more
dehumanized and the replicants become
more and more human and at the end they
meet and the distinction is gone but
this Fusion of Descartes and the
replicants is a tragedy it's not a
victory where the replicants become
humanized and there's some victory by
Humanity over inhumanity this is
horrifying because he is now as they are
so the theme of the novel is completely
and essentially retain
right so this is uh you know
quite an interesting
set of observations by dick about the
success or lack of success in adapting
the novel he also says and this is where
we're going to close at one point that
they're
too successful projects that kind of
connect up but they are two distinct
things this is why it was so important
that he didn't rewrite and reissue the
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep along
the lines of the movie you've got two
different things I would say to bring
this to to an end that in my view the
novel is a better piece of work than the
movie however great the movie is but
dick seemed to have been pretty happy
with the results and so there is where
we will close this session of Worlds of
speculative fiction
thank you